The vision with a distributed file server is that there is no central server any
more. Each file is distributed across several servers. What does it mean to
avoid the unscalability of a central server? We want to take a file and
distribute it across several different nodes in
the local area network. Since the DFS is
implemented across all the disks in the network,
if a client wants to read or write a
file then it actually is contacting all the
servers, potentially, to get the data that is looking
for. And which means that since each file
is distributed across all of these different servers, the
idle bandwidth that's available cumulatively across all of
these servers can be used to serve the needs
of every individual client. Also, this allows
distributing the management of the metadata that
is associated with the files among the
server nodes that are available. Furthermore, we have
more memories available in all of these
servers cumulatively, which means that we have a
bigger. Memory footprint available for implementing a
file cache, including all of the server memories,
plus the memories that may be there in the
clients as well. And that's where we can actually
go towards cooperative caching among the clients as well.
So, in the extreme, we can treat all the
nodes in the cluster, whether we call them. S1 or c1, we can look at all of the
nodes and say, they're all the same with interchangeable
roles as clients or servers. That is, we can actually
make this DFS a serverless file system. If we allow
the responsibility of managing the files. Saving the files, cashing
the files, equally distributed among all the nodes of the
class here so the nodes are interchangeable between clients and servers.